It would be way easier for us to get on
this video
>> [music]
>> and say crazy doom and gloom things.
You're going to die tomorrow.
>> Because of AI.
>> we could just say really provocative
statements that sound like sci-fi, that
sound like The Matrix, and that would
surely get more clicks
>> Yes.
>> than us being like, "It's going to be
fine.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm going to go separate. It's going to
be great."
>> This is Dalton plus Michael, and today
we're going to talk about controversial
topic.
Why humanity will be great
with AI.
You heard it here first.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> So, um I'm sure people watching have
consumed the news that, you know,
it's this weird kind of human American
thing like we're racing towards
advancing AI, which we all know will
destroy civilization.
It's a little confusing, Dalton.
And so, we thought maybe we would make
the case on how the world would be a
better place for this thing that we're
racing towards.
What do you think?
>> We are all bombarded with messages
>> Yes.
>> about the negative ways that AI is going
to hurt us constantly.
>> Yes.
>> And maybe to start with, let's talk
about the history of the labs and let's
talk about the history of AI cuz I think
this will help give context to how we
ended up here. The reason OpenAI was
started
was
>> fear.
>> Fear
>> [laughter]
>> that Google would create a
superintelligence
>> Yes.
>> and that it would be locked up inside of
Google
>> Yes.
>> and it'd be like if Google had, you
know, the infinite money glitch and they
didn't give it to anyone else, and that
would probably be bad for humanity.
>> Yes.
>> And so, the very
original pitch for the nonprofit was,
"Let's create a nonprofit that is open,
hence the name OpenAI,
>> Yes.
>> the innovations of AI would be shared
with humanity
>> Yes.
>> and it would also be more likely uh
safe, it would be more likely pro-social
for humans if it was done in like a
non-profit consortium than locked inside
of a corporation.
>> We all think of AI as almost a consumer
product now, but it I don't think that
was
the form factor wasn't understood. So,
when people were afraid of Google having
it, it wasn't even clear
that they would give it to
>> Correct. Who would they What would they
use it for? Like it was it was that
wasn't clear.
>> the argument was Google has the most
data, it has the most money, and it has
the most compute. Yes.
>> so, given those starting conditions
maybe they'll just keep, you know,
intelligence in a cage, and yeah.
Use it to run Google, and like that's
bad for humanity.
>> Exactly.
>> Right?
>> Combine that with a lot of the
researchers that worked in this stuff,
the the less wrong community, and all
those folks. Safety was a key part of
the message boards that the researchers
creating the stuff were really worried
about. I'm not saying that's bad, by the
way. I'm just saying this infected their
brain. This was a huge part of getting
into AI was debating safety
>> Yes.
>> constantly. In addition,
um
Anthropic, which ended up being pretty
important, when it split off from OpenAI
it was the safety folks who I believe at
the time
argued that they would be more safe than
OpenAI, and that OpenAI was not safe
enough in their approach. Did I Did I
miss anything there?
>> argument. Yeah. And all the news, or the
vast majority of news we consume on AI
is filtered through social networks that
gets more clicks on negative stories
than positive stories.
>> Yep.
>> So, all of the original kind of stories
were based on fear. All of the way that
we consume things, we see more eyeballs
based on fear.
>> Yep. If you think about the way, um
recommendation algorithms work
it is much easier, it would be way
easier for us to get on this video
and say crazy doom and gloom things
>> You're going to die tomorrow.
>> Right? Like we we could just say really
provocative statements
>> Yes.
>> that sound like sci-fi, that sound like
The Matrix, and that would surely get
more clicks
>> Yes.
>> than us being like, "It's going to be
fine.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm going to go separate. It's going to
be great."
>> It's going to be great.
>> That is such a harder thing um
to have [clears throat] go viral. And so
even the the fundamental algorithms that
are recommending content to us are
rewarding
>> Yes.
>> click-baity, super negative stuff.
>> If you're a normal person, this must be
so confusing, right? Cuz it's like, why
are we racing towards the thing
that even the creators of the thing
thinks going to kill us all? That's got
to be the most confusing thing
in the world.
Whereas, I actually think that the other
story a lot of people believe and just
nobody talks about.
>> And simple stories that are easy to
understand go more viral, like
AI is going to kill us all. One one
example of this is the water thing. I
think a huge percentage of people, if
the topic of AI comes up,
>> [__]
>> think that like the water is drink's
water.
And if you go and actually, you know, do
your own research on this one, the
original research
had like a um numerical error, I
believe, on how much [laughter] water
was used. And it's like a tiny fraction
of how much water like golf courses use.
And so whatever, do your own research on
this one, but basically, somehow, if you
just talk to normal people,
>> Yes.
>> they're convinced that the AI is going
to evaporate all the water on Earth
>> Yes.
>> and that
they should use, you know, ChatGPT
sparingly to save water.
>> [laughter]
>> And so so again, I'm we're just setting
this up. This is a tricky
>> Yes.
>> narrative zone that we're in.
>> [laughter]
>> And so even though it is harder to
articulate a positive view of the future
with all of these starting conditions,
we're going to try, and we think you all
should too.
>> Yes.
>> And that I would argue
to prepare yourselves, your children,
uh if you're running a company, your
company for the future.
>> Yes.
>> Being able to explain what role and
purpose we have in the future and why
life matters and you should be excited
about things
is
completely necessary.
>> Yes. I think before getting to the
macro, I'd like to start with the micro,
right? So, with my personal usage of AI,
I have been surprised. You know, about a
year ago I started exploring the
challenges of the city of San Francisco.
And to be honest, without AI,
I would have been screwed, right? I had
to do
effectively years worth of public policy
research to understand our budget, where
we spend our money, our health price
crisis, like all of these things. And
without AI, I would have been stuck.
>> Yep.
>> I was trying to consume information that
no one person had.
And so, just being able to use AI to do
research, to research all of the
reporting that the city does, academic
reporting, comparative reporting on how
other cities do with drug crises,
incredible. The other thing that I was
able to do is so much of San Francisco
city data is being made available
through API online.
I'm a business guy.
That was useless to me until the last
year. And with Claude, suddenly,
I can see what the city's thrown one
response time is. I can see how dirty
different parts of the city are. I can
see which departments are faster or
slower. Like, there's so much stuff that
I can see to understand what's happening
in the city. So, for my personal usage,
I was just like,
well, obviously, this is making me more
productive. Like, it's hard to think
that I was a productive person before
this. And then watching my kid use AI,
you know, I've got a an eighth grader,
I'm sorry, eighth grader, an 8-year-old
who uses AI.
And the amount of creativity it it's so
weird. Like, in some ways
the amount he's able to explore his
imagination, the amount that he's
reading, the amount that he's thinking.
Like, he wants to design video games.
All kids love designing video games who
like video games. He can do it now. And
so, from a micro perspective, at least
in my life, it's like it's so clearly
been empowering that like
I have to take a step back and basically
be like, all right, let me separate the
narrative from reality. If it's being
really empowering in my life and my
kids' life,
let me maybe search for how it could be
empowering for humanity. And how do you
get to this? The way I think about it is
the following. Um
I think pop culture reflects back to us
like pretty good critiques of what's
going on in the world. And if you think
about great movies like Office Space
>> Yes.
>> or television
>> shows like The Office.
>> Yes.
>> I think if you if you think about them,
>> [laughter]
>> what they're poking fun at is
people that are just like you and me
that have agency, that wanted to good
work, and that want to have purpose and
meaning in their lives.
>> Yes.
>> And they are trapped in an environment
>> that is stupid and meaningless,
and their work has nothing to do with
outcomes. And it's just this like it's
literally comedic. It's funny how there
is no purpose
>> Yes.
>> in the work that they do and their
co-workers do.
>> Yes.
>> Customers don't matter. Their work
doesn't matter.
>> They have perfectly good brains,
and their companies are not using them.
>> Yeah.
And they're relatable. We can all put
ourselves in the shoes of the
characters, and we're like, man, can you
imagine
what a stupid environment that is?
>> But that's most people who work on
Earth.
>> And so,
the positive vision I would get
>> Yes.
>> is that if a lot of the meaningless work
that you have to do to do your job isn't
necessary,
>> Yes.
>> and that you can be more aligned with
helping customers or helping with the
vision of what the company is supposed
to do,
>> Yeah.
>> people will have more meaning in their
lives and work will mean more to them.
>> I would double down on this. You know,
in my experience in big companies,
the people on the ground who have at
least authority of what is built or
done,
often have the most contact with the
problem and the customer.
>> Yep.
>> And we've kind of built companies so the
people up here decide what's done and
the people here know what's going on.
>> [laughter]
>> And like that's
that's modern organizational design.
And I would say there's probably a good
reason for that because the people down
here, in one reasonable week of work,
could only do so much. It was
relatively hard for them to have a wide
set of skills, etc., etc. So you got to
compartmentalize and so you have to
coordinate and people are expensive and
da da da da. And so, I don't think this
organization is dumb. I think it evolved
from the best we could do. Now that
person on the ground has the capability
of a lot more people.
>> Yeah.
>> To your point, now the person on the
ground has a lot more time. I really am
excited about how organizations will be
built and the people who are closest to
the problems
have 10x the ability and 10x the time.
We shouldn't think that the solutions we
have today are good.
>> [laughter]
>> Like like we don't think the solutions
we had 100 years ago were good.
>> Yeah.
>> 100 years from now, they're going to
look at the stuff that we think is
solved today and they're going to be
like, that was the Dark Ages.
>> I think if a founder were asking me
about this in office hours, I think what
I would tell them to do is to look to
the labs
>> Yeah.
>> as a little window into the future.
Maybe not the far future, but maybe 12
months, 18 months ahead of us. And so,
let me be specific.
How many people that work at the labs
have fake email jobs?
Maybe more than zero, I don't know. But
I'm going to guess that most people, if
you interview them like, "Oh, what do
you do at Anthropic?" They're not going
to be like, "Oh, I create PowerPoints."
>> Yes, I push paper.
>> Push [laughter] paper.
Probably there are not a ton of those
people. That would be my assumption.
Maybe I'm wrong. I'd also would say that
the labs keep hiring people. And then
when someone is like Dalton, like,
there's not going to be any jobs, like
these companies are all going to have
one employee, they're going to be
unicorns. I'm like, "Well,
maybe, but
I think that if the labs keep hiring
people,
>> [laughter]
>> that that's probably a signal that
that's a good idea. And my mental model
for that is
if someone is worth more than their
salary, if they generate more revenue or
more value for the company than what it
cost to pay them, why wouldn't you keep
doing that? If you're worried about job
loss, it's that you don't think that
certain job functions could be done
on an incremental basis by humans
anymore. And I don't know, I think that
lacks vision. Clearly the labs are are
turning people. So again, to be
specific,
think about the people that I know being
hired at the labs. They're on these tiny
teams.
>> Yes.
>> They're you know, I know the people
working on Codex, I know the people
working on Claude code. They're on a
tiny team, they're talking to users,
they're using their own tools, and
they're shipping really fast. And
they're having a really good time.
>> Yes.
>> And they certainly have a lot of
purpose.
>> Yes.
>> We could argue perhaps too much, but
they all
>> [laughter]
>> Just kidding. I'm just saying they all
feel like they're on a mission.
>> Yes.
>> And so, they're so fired up, they're
working so hard, and they can understand
how their personal effort is helping the
company and helping the users. And I
would argue that is a perfect blueprint
for what every company should be should
be doing or thinking, right?
>> Well, I think this is what so
interesting about startups and about
companies that are built from the ground
up with AI
is because
you can imagine that you don't even have
to imagine it. Like that is what will
organically happen
if you believe in AI and you're starting
a new company. I think this also
represents the challenge
in talking to existing companies, right?
You know, if I'm trying to pitch
AI to a bunch of MBAs that run a large
company
and I'm trying to say like imagine a
world where you can have
a hundreds of small autonomous teams
that can make massive impact. That
sounds scary as [__]
>> Yep.
>> Whereas if I say to them imagine a world
where we can fire half your employees,
they're like well
stock price this that da da da
I think the companies that
embrace these new ways of organization,
that embrace pushing responsibility down
>> Yeah.
>> are going to thrive. But we've seen with
every tech transformation
some dinosaurs have to die.
>> and as we're recording this um
it recently came out that Meta
apologized to their employees for
dehumanizing them and going so nuts into
AI
>> in a top-down
>> in a top-down way. And so
the difference between Labs hiring
people and giving them
>> responsibility
>> and resources
>> [laughter]
>> is very different than like hey cool,
you work at Meta um
install this spyware on your computer so
we can track your clickstream and now
you're on the data labeling team. Not
great. And so again, I I would argue
institutions of the future
are going to find a way to translate
their employees' jobs
into giving them meaning, into giving
them purpose
>> Yes.
>> and to giving them agency
>> um along with the tools to do so and the
people that do that are going to win.
>> Well, and and I think the big companies
that have fear right now, it's like so
silly because I understand how you would
have fear
in a large company where to get
information from the ground up, it has
to go through eight people's hands and
it's going to get the the the turd will
be shined over and over again, right?
So, you can't really trust the
information you're getting, right? But,
if you're an executive, especially if
you have a tech company, you can use AI
now to get ground information. Right?
Like you have access to your own
database. Like you have access to raw
customer data.
You can monitor what's happening in your
company
in a way that should give you the
confidence to push responsibility down.
And like you just have to learn how to
use the tools, you know? And And it was
funny cuz I was talking to somebody
who was at a large tech company and this
company was going through a like, "Oh,
we need to get all of our employees
using AI."
And he said something really interesting
to me. It's like, "It's probably more
important to get the managers using AI
than employees."
Because once the managers realize how
much the organization can change if
they're using AI, like that's when
you're going to actually see the real
change, right? If that manager is not
AI-pilled, it almost doesn't matter that
their employees are.
And I was like, "Huh."
I don't see any company advertising
how much does our senior team use AI.
Right? Right? No, but we're the
That's not
>> Yeah.
>> for us, right? How is it going to help
us? It's going to help the employees,
right?
>> [laughter]
>> You know, a little bit of what this
reminds me of, I I forget if I've talked
about this one of our videos before, but
there was a blog post from a writer at
Bloomberg a few years ago that stuck in
my brain for years. And he talked about
how a lot of businesses in the world
could use really bright people to run
them. And that there's actually a lack
of talent to
run certain businesses where the owners
are retiring. So, the example this
writer used was plumbing businesses. You
know, there's all these plumbing
businesses, the owner needs to sell
them, the owner needs to retire, and
it's pretty hard to go to the Harvard
campus and be like
>> Do you want to do
>> Do you want to go? And so, his argument
is that what private equity is
is a whitewashing to put
to say like, "Oh, do you want a job in
private equity?" And you're like, "Of
course I want it."
>> You can do a plumbing roll-up.
>> And [laughter] that a lot of the actual
jobs
Like, what you actually do when you go
work in private equity is often to work
on plumbing companies.
>> Traditional businesses, yeah.
>> um making
a job in plumbing legible to super smart
people is actually the function in
society that private equity firms are
producing.
>> I love that, because you know what? We
still need [__] plumbers.
>> It's [laughter] actually really
important. And so, so again, where I'm
going with this is that the narrative
matters so much.
>> Yes.
>> And then if an organization wants to
attract top talent and have that talent
feel this is worthy of their time
>> Mhm.
>> you have to
make it legible to them. You have to
give them
>> They're like
>> the pitch like, "Oh, private equity,
that's the coolest job you can get after
graduation."
>> Not
>> "I'm moving to Alabama and running a
plumbing company." is not something you
hear.
>> I love that. You know, as you're saying
that, I'm like, I remember a friend of a
close friend of mine who got a
consulting job at a
good consulting firm, got paid a lot of
salary. And 4 days a week he was in
Pittsburgh.
Uh he lived in New York.
>> He lived in [laughter] New York, but 4
days a week he was in Pittsburgh. And he
was working for like a regional bank,
and the number one job he was figuring
out is like where to open branches.
>> Yeah.
>> And and how do you convince that kid to
do that?
>> him it's consulting job. You give him
the brand, you give him
>> Yes.
>> To wrap this up
if we look back,
Neil deGrasse Tyson said something that
really was funny. He was like doing some
video on how like
science actually helps.
And he was like, you know, humanity for
thousands and thousands of years like
our um
lifespan did not increase.
And then like in the last 150 years it's
increased a lot and that was science and
like you're told all these things like
plastic or like the new agriculture like
all these things are killing you but
like objectively
>> [laughter]
>> lifespan's increased as these things are
invented.
Science helps. What do you think is the
world our kids or grandkids might live
in
that was made better by AI? Like what
are some of the things that we take for
granted right now
that our kids or grandkids are going to
be like, I can't believe
>> Yeah.
>> that was cool.
>> Well, I mean to start with health care
alone and lifespan
>> Yes.
>> and solving cancer and heart disease. I
mean that's already happening and will
only increase of
you know, producing new drugs and new
interventions that
>> How many diseases do we live with today
as fait accompli?
>> Yeah.
>> Are going to people are going to look
back and be like
>> 100%
>> That's weird.
>> [laughter]
>> How about car fatalities?
>> Yes.
>> Like there will be a moment
>> It's barbaric how many people die right
now in car accidents. It's
horrible.
>> I remember I used to commute in New York
City and it was just like there's a
fatal accident every day.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's on the news but not like as a
tragedy as like here's how the traffic
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> as like here's here's which highway to
take to avoid it. That's going to seem
barbaric.
>> I think the bar is going to be raised on
finding meaning in life and I think
people are going to have more time and
tools
to find meaning in what they're doing
and to feel like they have
the mind space to be creative. Again, if
you look at humanity, humans used to
have to be like farming until the sun
went down. If you
there was not a lot of time to do stuff
that wasn't subsistence farming. To make
enough food for them to live.
Where I'm going with this is that more
leisure time is good. And that
there is an opportunity for everyone to
feel like they have
you know, time to be who they want to
be, time to do what they want to do. And
that we should be really excited about
that, that our kids get to have even
more of that time than we did.
>> Why are we so afraid of losing the
office space jobs? And I understand like
if we can tell ourselves a story that
there will be no other jobs, but like
it will be the first time in human
history that there are no other jobs.
>> Actually, you know what? I think the
pushback would be authority figures,
people that would go and make a video
about a topic like this, have some deep
ulterior motive and agenda of trying to
screw people. Like I think people have
this
you know, somehow every new thing that's
going to come out
is somehow going to screw them.
I somehow that's just baked into
people's minds.
>> I'm trying to it let's say we're the
authority figures here.
>> Yeah, yeah, we're trying somehow we're
putting out messages that are like we
have some devious
uh intention.
>> I have to think hard.
>> That's what they would say.
>> In another video we will describe
We have to think hard about our devious
intentions.
>> Yeah, but I'm just trying to say like
when new stuff comes out, it's like oh,
they're not really telling you, you
know, big big oil is behind this.
There's some ulterior motive.
>> And and I just hate this cuz it kind of
it comes back to this narrative
that pains me
that I think is somehow an American
narrative that like things are getting
worse when they're actually getting
better.
And it's it's
I might have brought this up before.
There's a book called Factfulness and in
the beginning of this book, there's like
this 10 or 20 question quiz.
And the whole funny part about this quiz
is that the author tells you
before he gives you the quiz, that you
will guess pessimistically on all of
these questions. And the questions like
the average education level of yada
yada, or you know, the accessibility of
electricity, yada. They're all these
kind of like population global like how
we're doing questions. And they He gives
you the answer.
>> He's like
>> you're going to guess pessimistic. So
whenever you pick an answer, just like
make
pick more optimistic.
And still, the vast majority of people
underestimate how good the world's doing
right now.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, I think our kids and grandkids
are going to look back at this hysteria
with a little bit of laughter, but also
a little bit of sadness.
And they're going to be like
these backwards people.
>> [laughter]
>> They were getting all this good stuff,
and they were convinced it was a trick.
>> Yeah.
>> They thought like, you know, it'd be
like us being like people who are afraid
of electricity. It's like, "What are you
doing? Like we need to
>> [laughter]
>> CAN WE GET LIKE
>> I WILL SAY THIS, if you're watching this
video and and you're just trying to be
utilitarian about it,
having a positive view on AI is
certainly going to help you more.
>> Yes.
>> Because you're going to learn how to use
it. You're going to learn how to thrive
with it, and you're going to be
around people who might not be.
>> Yep.
>> And so,
>> even if you just want to look at it that
way.
>> [laughter]
>> Anyways, any last thoughts to share?
>> I would just challenge everyone in your
own life
to articulate why
you're excited and optimistic about how
these changes are going to help you, to
help the next generations, and help make
that a reality.
>> Yes.
>> You know?
>> And I I would say
don't take a one-off experience with AI
a year ago
and make it your entire experience with
AI. Right? Like understand this is
changing. For any of you who are kind of
as old as us, like the internet got a
lot better in the '90s and then it got a
lot better in the 2000s and like if you
just took a snapshot of the internet in
1995 and you're like that's internet,
you're kind of missing the boat here.
And so I actually think one way to get
really positive about AI is to use it to
solve a problem in your own life. And
[snorts] like you might be shocked
um how good it can be. Cool. Cheers.
>> All right. Thanks, Michael.